[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: So take a
look at the reading list.
And you will see there's
various things that
are starred on there that
are on today's lecture two.
There's readings by Kreps
and by Nicholson and Snyder.
The lecture does not
overlap entirely,
but it is close
in many respects.
So I urge you to take a look at.
There's one Kreps and
two Nicholson and Snyder.
I also mentioned last time, but
it might have been abstract,
the review sheets.
This is lecture
one from last time.
It's a review sheet--
pretty comprehensive,
but also quite specific.
So you should be
looking at these things
before, during, or
especially after the lecture,
even if you think you
understand the material.
Take a hand at this.
I certainly have included
questions almost verbatim
like this on the midterms,
so you might as well do it
in advance.
And I'm going to read out
just one or two of these.
Obviously, we don't have
time to do too many of them.
I would say I'm almost picking
at random, but not quite.
So the fact that I pick
some and not others
does not mean that some are
more important than others,
but only I want to
practice with you.
So for example, this one--
Angrist distinguishes
randomized trials
from quasi-experiments
or natural experiments.
Please explain what he
means by this distinction
and give one example from
each of the two groups,
meaning from quasi-randomized
controlled trials and one
from quasi-experiments.
I know you're new to this,
so I hesitate to call on you.
So it would be
wonderful if someone
were to volunteer to
answer this question.
STUDENT: I think I
could make a go at it.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: All
right, please go ahead.
STUDENT: Oh, yeah, so an
actual experiment is randomized
controlled trials where
you actually randomly take
a group of people,
randomly select
some to be a control group, some
to be the experimental group.
And then you apply some
change to one of them,
to the experimental group,
and track the outcomes.
A natural quasi-experiment would
be more if something happens--
for example, one state raises
the minimum wage and another
state doesn't.
And you can track a difference.
So it wasn't an actual
experiment, but you can still--
but it sort of behaves a
bit like an experiment.
So you can try to tease
apart the causality there.
And then I can't remember
the rest of the question.
Sorry.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No, it's fine.
Do you remember an
example from any of those?
STUDENT: From a
natural experiment,
that would be like the
Moving to Opportunity.
I remember that being mentioned,
where people were effectively
randomly chosen to be given
housing opportunities to move.
And then that was tracked.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Excellent.
OK.
Yeah, and the other
RCT we did was
the paying bicycle messengers
temporarily higher wages.
RCTs are where we are
with these vaccines,
just to have an obvious
analog to the widely used RCTs
in medical trials.
But we like to frame
questions that way.
Thank you, Charles.
And I also went and
read some of the things
you recommended last time.
Thank you.
Let's see, let me
pick another one.
So Varian speaks of big data as
consisting of machine learning
and data science.
What do those
techniques accomplish
and what do they
fail to accomplish?
And again, let me
ask for volunteers.
STUDENT: So I
remember you talking
about what they
fail to accomplish,
where it's difficult
to actually construct
the explanation behind the
phenomena that you observe.
Instead, it just gives
you good predictive power
where you can construct
accurate models,
but not necessarily
explain them.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Excellent.
That's exactly right.
The example was just
because we see more police
in the community, that
doesn't mean it causes crime.
And I said something about
the example's a bit more
problematic these days than
it was when Varian used that
as an example.
But it's still the case that
we need to out the causality
whether it runs from crime
to police or police to crime.
All right, so there are other
important questions in here,
but I'm a little leery
about taking too, too
much of the lecture time.
So these are called
review sheets.
And I think you'll
find it is not hard.
It really is just a matter of
keeping up with the lecture
and thinking about
this afterwards, along
with those starred readings.
So today, this is
about consumer choice.
Remember, we're
studying economies,
but we need to build and
analyze the building blocks, one
of which is consumer behavior.
So that's what this
lecture is about.
The whole economy consists of
consumers with preferences,
and endowments, and
consumption sets,
and firms with technology.
We're going to focus on consumer
choice over possible bundles
they might want to buy or eat.
We're going to describe some
assumptions that characterize
what's known as rational, as
opposed to irrational consumer
choice.
And then we're going to go
to this application, which
is maximizing utility
for a given budget.
Let me just say now,
because I may not
remember to do it
later, when we get
to this application
of maximizing utility
subject to a budget, it's what
we call "partial equilibrium."
We take, as Matzkin
would say, some things
as exogenous to the
consumer choice--
namely, their income and
the prices that they face.
Those are like data or givens.
And then we're looking at what
they choose to buy or to eat.
It's partial
equilibrium in the sense
that we're not trying to explain
where the prices come from
or where the income comes from.
But when we put
this building block
together with the other ones,
with other households and/or
with firms, then
we'll have what's
called "general
equilibrium," which
is the endogenous determination
of prices, and so on.
OK, so let's call capital X here
a consumer's consumption set.
Two elements of the set called x
and y are potential consumption
bundles.
You should be aware
and a bit leery
that the notation changes
from time to time.
Sometimes in the
slides that follow,
we're about to say x is one
bundle and y is another one.
Many times we'll
go more abstract,
and talk about a
vector x of dimension n
where they're all
x's, x1 through x n.
And indeed, when we start
to talk about more than one
consumer, like consumer i--
that's his or her name--
we can talk about the
consumption set x sub i.
The bundle x i is
still a vector,
but it has a little
i subscript in front
of the 1 to n commodity labels.
But there's no point in
being overly detailed when
we don't need it, so we'll
drop the i mostly today.
I don't think it
appears anywhere.
And as I said for
the graphs, we're
going to be using x
and y quite a bit.
Now, one warning-- should
have something flashing
on the screen--
stop.
Pause-- which is
there's something mind
numbing about the notation.
It's useful.
We will build up all
the tools with it.
But we'll lose sight
of the applications.
So I will bend over backwards
to pop in a slide here or there
and say some words about
how this can be used.
But the point,
although abstract now,
is that the artillery where
you're going to create
applies to wheat and rice, but
it also applies to locations.
It applies to dates and time.
It applies to shocks
and states of the world.
So once we do it one way
with this powerful but boring
notation, we can use it in
many actual applications
and villages.
With the exception that here,
we're actually spelling out
the consumption set.
So you can see that.
Can you see it when I'm
moving the cursor around?
All right, I'll have
to work on my tool kit.
So there's two goods
here-- bread and leisure.
And the consumption
set is all of this.
It has an upper bound.
Why?
Because leisure is
measured in hours,
and there's no more
than 24 hours, a day.
So that's one example
of a consumption set.
Here's another-- there's
two goods, x1 and x2.
x1 can take on any value--
integers, rational, or
irrational numbers from 0
to infinity.
But x2 takes on
discrete values--
integers-- 1, 2, 3.
So all these lines,
including the 0 line,
represent elements in
the consumption set.
Here's an example with some
limited time and geography.
You can consume a piece of
bread, or bread in general,
in Washington at noon
or in New York at noon.
But you can't be in two
places at the same time.
So in this case, you
have the x and y-axis
being the consumption set.
And here's a subsistence.
If you don't eat enough--
and we'll talk about starvation
in medieval villages soon--
you die.
So you have to have either
four slices of white bread,
or four slices of brown bread,
or something in between.
But you can't go less than that.
Those things are not
in the consumption set.
So that's the set in
which commodity bundles
lie for the house.
So what about their preferences?
We're going to begin with
this primitive, which
looks like a weak
inequality, but it's
actually script or squiggly, to
denote that it's a preference
relation, which is an ordering.
So if you give me two elements
of the consumption set x and y,
this ordering will
tell me whether x
is weakly preferred or at least
as good as y in the consumer's
ordering.
From that primitive, we can
create strict preference
for any two goods, x and y.
If x is strictly
preferred to y, that
means that x is at
least as good as y,
but y is not at
least as good as x.
Indifference can
also be constructed
from this primitive.
Namely, if x is
indifferent to y,
then x is at least as good as y,
and y is at least as good as x.
This preference relation then
represents the preferences
of each individual--
in this case,
as I said, we've
deleted individual i.
This would be true
for all of them.
Preference relations
obviously can
be different across
different households.
What do we mean by "rational?"
Rational choice means that
those preferences are complete,
transitive, and continuous.
And let me just go
over them briefly.
"Completeness" means that
any two bundles x and y
are ranked relative
to each other.
So given x and y, either x
is strictly preferred to y,
y is strictly preferred
to x, or the household
is indifferent between the two.
And the point here is that
any two bundles x and y
can be ranked and
compared to each other.
It's a complete ordering.
Transitive-- if x
is at least as good
as y, y is at
least as good as z,
then it must also be true that
x is at least as good as z.
So we will use this later.
It's like an internal
consistency criterion.
You may only see choices
between x and y and y and z,
but if the consumer
is rational, you
can infer something
about the way
they would behave
when they're faced
with a choice between x
and z that we actually
didn't see them make.
And finally, we have
continuity, which intuitively
means if we have x
strictly preferred to y,
and we have some other
bundle x prime which
is close to x, since x and x
prime are close to each other
and x is preferred to
y, then x prime is also
going to be preferred to y.
In other words, the
preference ordering
isn't jumping around hugely as
we move around the commodity
space.
So we start with this
underlying preference ordering,
but we can do a representation
as a utility function
just by preserving
the rank ordering.
So for example, if x is
at least as good as y,
then we come up with
the utility function u,
which maps the
entire consumption
set into real
numbers in such a way
that we give at least
as high of a number
to x as we assign under u to y.
One thing to note is that many
utility functions would work.
If we start with
this primitive, we
could have 2 times u or some
multiplicative function of u.
It's going to preserve
the ranked utility
numbers across the bundles.
So this is referred to
as an ordinal rather than
a cardinal utility function.
In the history of
economics, utility functions
were invented by Jeremy
Bentham in England.
Jeremy left in his will
that after he died,
he wanted to be
embalmed and preserved,
and that once a year he should
have tea with his friends.
So Jeremy still-- or at
least when I was last there--
is sitting in kind of a glass
container in the lobby of one
of the buildings at University
of College of London.
There was some vandalism.
Someone removed his
head at one point.
But anyway, I always
think of Jeremy
when I think of
utility functions.
And forgive my morbid
sense of humor.
Here's a theorem-- any
preference relation that
can be represented by a
continuous utility function
is rational.
OK, that's a lot to take in.
Any preference
relation that can be
represented as a continuous
utility function is rational.
Well, "completeness" means
we're assigning utility numbers
to any bundle and
any pair of bundles.
So pick two, look at
their utility numbers,
and we have the ranking
implied by the utility.
Some utility numbers
are higher than others.
So we can rank everything.
That's why when we have
a utility function,
the ranking is complete.
The ranking is transitive
because if the utility number
of a is greater than or equal
to the utility number of b,
and b's utility number
is higher than c,
then we have transitivity under
the ordinary weak inequality.
So the one implies the
other, essentially.
In this case, we're going
from the existence of-- oh,
and we're given
continuous, which
was the third property of a
rational preference ordering.
So that's embedded
in the utility.
So obviously, two bundles
which are close to each other
are going to have very
close utility values.
There's something very
deceptive about this lecture
because no slide is
particularly hard, I think.
Of course you should
alert me if otherwise.
But yet somehow, when we
go through all of them,
you'll be empowered with the
tools of consumer theory.
So it is definitely
worth doing this well.
Local non-satiation
is another property.
It says that if you're given
an x in the consumption set
and an arbitrary
small number epsilon,
there exists some other element
y in the consumption set
so that when we're within an
epsilon neighborhood of x,
we find this y.
And y is preferred to x.
In other words, it's a
little weaker than global,
which is on the next slide.
Local just means you start
with x, draw a circle
around it in Euclidean space--
two-dimensional, or a sphere, or
in higher dimensional objects.
And you can always
find something
in that area, however small,
that is strictly preferred
to the starting point x.
Eventually, we'll get to
competitive equilibria
or entire economies.
Are competitive
equilibria optimal?
The answer may be no if we
lose this local non-satiation.
So it will sneak back up on us.
In other words,
there's no bliss point.
This is the dismal
view of economics,
I suppose, that more is
always preferred to less,
and people just
can't get enough.
Here's a more global view of
it, which is with two goods.
We start with this bundle here.
This whole hatched-in
area has more of one
or the other or both goods.
And it's the weakly or strictly
preferred set relative to that.
In fact, if they
value both goods,
then even if you
keep one constant,
you're increasing the other.
So it's a strictly
preferred set.
This, which has less
of one or the other
of both relative to the starting
point, is the worse-than set.
So back to rank ordering,
we start here and say,
what about a bundle here?
Well, that's strictly preferred.
Start here, what
about going southwest?
Then the original bundle
is strictly preferred.
But we leave some question marks
in these off-diagonal elements,
essentially.
Because it has more of one
good and less than another.
So a priori we're
not able to say
what the consumer would choose
without providing more details.
But we can provide those
details if we go back to, say,
the representation of
the utility function.
So we pick a bundle,
and it's associated
with a given level of utility.
Remember Jeremy Bentham.
And then we ask what other
values in this consumption set
would generate the same utility
level as the starting point?
And that's the entire set
of bundles on this curve.
So this is called an
"indifference curve,"
in the sense that
these two bundles--
x1, y1 and x2, y2--
under the consumer's preferences
are indifferent to each other.
It might have been
better to call it
an "isoutility curve," because
that language is even closer
to what it is.
And later in the class, when
we get to production functions,
we can talk about isoquants.
And later we can
talk about isocosts.
And this is isoutility--
same utility.
Or traditionally, it's called
the "indifference curve."
Now, this is drawn with a
certain diminishing slope,
and I'll come back
to that momentarily.
Well, of course, there's
more than one curve.
Because under a utility
function, it's complete.
So everything has a ranking.
Let's jump up here--
utility levels are higher.
Jump up here, higher still.
So as you move northeast,
we're moving in the direction
of strictly increasing utility.
In fact, stuff is going on
between these curves, too.
It's just utility levels
that are between U1 and U2.
So you typically
graphically just
draw one or a finite number.
We don't try to fill
the whole thing out
because then it
would just go black.
Let's try this diagram.
This is indifference
curves that are crossing.
Note that A is northeast of B,
has more of both goods X and Y.
So A must be strictly
preferred to B.
However, A is on the same
indifference curve as E,
the indifference
curve labeled U1.
And E is on the same
indifference curve as B,
the indifference curve U2.
Under transitivity,
if the consumer
is indifferent between A and
E and indifferent between E
and B, then by
transitivity, the consumer
should be indifferent
between A and B.
But we started out by saying
that the consumer strictly
prefers A to B. So we end
up with a contradiction.
Hence, indifference
curves can never cross.
So let's come back to the slope.
Let's define the marginal
rate of substitution,
the willingness to give
up one good for another,
as the negative slope of
the indifference curve.
So that is, the marginal rate of
substitution, is how much of Y
you have to get when
you give up 1 unit of X
while keeping utility
constant at U1.
So that curve and
this number tell
us something about trade-offs
that a household would
willingly do to be
indifferent, or potentially,
later, to even gain.
So if you go back
to this slide, this
is a diminishing marginal
rate of substitution.
The slope is getting
less and less.
It's obviously negative because
when you get more of one good,
you're willing to
give up the other.
The issue is how much.
If you start off with
a modest amount of X1
and a relatively
large amount of Y1,
and you move down this
curve, the marginal rate
of substitution
would be this slope.
But if you gave the household
more of X and less of Y,
the slope becomes less
and less because here,
as you move pointwise down,
you have more and more X.
But X is less and less
valued because you
have more and more of it.
You have less and less Y,
so Y is more and more valued
as you give up more of it.
And so to make this
movement [INAUDIBLE],,
you require more and more X as
you surrender a given unit of Y
in order to maintain
the indifference
on the indifference curve.
I mean, down here,
it's almost flat.
You just have so much of
good X that variation of it
doesn't change
utility very much.
So you don't have to change Y.
And here, it's almost vertical.
So we normally assume the
marginal rate of substitution
is decreasing, just
as in that diagram.
And the intuition is they
want things to be balanced.
And then we're about
to get to notions
of convexity and concavity,
but I'll wait for that slide.
One thing I want
to say right away
is that the marginal
rate of substitution
doesn't have to be decreasing.
If indifference curves are
linear, as they are here,
then the slope is the same.
It's a line, after all.
So the marginal
rate of substitution
is not diminishing,
it's constant.
And here, we have
our classic case,
which is the way
they're typically drawn.
Here, it's the
opposite, which is
if you start at
this point of the L
and move in the direction
of having more of good X
you would gain no extra utility.
Likewise, if you started at
this point and had more Y,
you would gain no extra utility.
The only way to achieve
higher levels of utility going
from U0 to U1, et
cetera, is to increase
both, and in the exact
same proportions.
So these are sometimes called
Leontiefian indifference
curves, although he really
created them in production,
and we'll get to
that in two lectures.
So the degree of
substitutability--
these are very curved, these
are linear, these are kinked--
is something called the
"elasticity of substitution."
So these are constant elasticity
of substitution curves
that are parameterized by
the degree of curvature.
And here are some
particular functions.
This one's called Cobb-Douglas.
He was an Economist at
Illinois, or Douglas was.
Senator Douglas-- I think he
was a Senator from Illinois when
it was an agricultural state.
I'd have to check
that to be sure.
So x to the power alpha,
y to the power of beta--
perfect complements,
which is this one is here,
you can see the ratio
I was referring to.
To maintain utility
constant, the ratio of y to x
has to be alpha over beta.
Perfect substitutes,
linear, constant elasticity
of substitution, this function.
And we will use these
for numerical examples,
and p sets, and so
on, from time to time.
OK, now we get to convexity,
and quasi-convexity, and all
of that stuff.
So a set X, like
a consumption set,
is convex if whenever you have
two separate bundles x and x
prime in the set, and you take a
linear combination of those two
points with weights alpha--
say alpha between 0 and 1--
then this new point
is also in the set.
So it's a standard
definition of a convex set.
A function is said to
be convex if whenever
you have two points x prime
and y prime, and x and x prime
and you evaluate the function
f, then the weighted average
of those two points over
here evaluated under f
is less than the
weighted average
in the range of the function.
So that's a definition
of a convex function.
The set of points on or above
the graph of a convex function
is convex.
So that's kind of linking
these two definitions together.
I'll show you the
picture momentarily.
A convex function and
negative of a convex function
is concave.
To define quasi-convex--
a function
f is not simply convex
but weaker quasi-convex
if whenever you evaluate
the two end points, and x,
and x prime, and take
the max of the two,
it's no less than the
function evaluated
at the weighted average.
And likewise, the negative
of a quasi-convex function
is said to be quasi-concave.
So what are we
going to use here?
I'll show you a
picture where we'll
display convexity of a set,
convexity of a function,
and the use of quasi-concavity.
So this is the one
that is consistent
with the definitions.
This is the one that is not.
So this indifference curve is a
curve in the space of x and y.
And it's convex,
actually strictly convex.
The set of points with
utility greater than
or equal to the
utility associated
with this indifference
curve is this hatched area.
And this is a convex set.
You pick any two points--
for example, this
one and this one--
and take a weighted
average, and you'll still
have a utility level which is
greater than the utility is
associated with U1.
If you looked at the definition
of quasi-concave utility
function, we take the
utility function which
is generating these
indifference curves, and say,
what's the utility at this point
under that utility function?
What's the utility at this point
Take the max of
those two, and then
show that the weighted
average on the line
gives a strictly
higher utility level.
So quasi-concave function
reverses the inequality here.
So the max of the utility
at each of the endpoints
is less than the utility
at the weighted average.
So that is tedious, and
it's a bit hard to absorb,
especially if you're not used
to using all of these things.
Anyway, this is the
good-looking picture,
and this one is ugly in the
sense that it violates every
single--
this property, this
utility indifference curve
is not convex.
It has some concave portion.
The set of bundles on or
above the indifference curve,
when you take weighted
averages of them,
you would be below the
indifference curve,
violating the property.
And similarly, if you take
this point and this point,
take the max of the two,
and take a weighted average,
the utility is actually
now less than, not greater.
That quasi-convexity
or concavity of utility
is a bit surprising.
It has to do with the ordinal
nature of the utility function.
We don't want to say a
function is necessarily
strictly concave, although that
would imply quasi-concavity.
But we could take another
transformation that
removes the strict
concavity, and it could still
be quasi-concavity.
It's clear by plotting
in the choice space
in this way, that
quasi-concavity
is what we want, although
we haven't really
talked about choices.
We're just talking
about rank ordering.
So marginal rate of
substitution defined a bit more
mathematically--
we have a utility
function over x1 and x2.
We can call the marginal
utility the derivative
of the utility with respect
to x1 or utility of x1,
likewise for x2.
Now, if we're moving along
an indifference curve,
we're changing the
quantities of x and y,
but we're keeping
utility constant.
So dU, or the total
differentiable of utility,
does not change as we move
along an indifference curve.
So dU here would be the
derivative of utility
with respect to X1 times dX1
plus the utility with respect
to marginal utility with
respect to X2 times dX2.
That's this expression.
This is going to be 0 by
definition of moving along
an indifference curve.
Since it's equal to 0,
we can solve for dX2.
I think you can visualize
what happens here.
dX2 divided by dX1
is equal to the ratio
of these marginal utilities.
Rather than derive
this every time,
although it's a bit
dangerous to memorize things,
basically in that
diagram, we have
x1 on the x-axis,
x2 on the y-axis.
And the marginal
rate of substitution
is the negative of
the marginal utility
on the x-axis and marginal
utility on the y-axis.
Another definition--
homothetic preferences--
so preferences are
homothetic means
that the marginal
rate of substitution
depends only on the
ratio of the goods
and not on the total quantity.
So a picture is worth
a thousand words.
Here's an indifference
curve, here's a point.
What is the marginal
rate of substitution?
The slope of that point,
of the curve at that point.
Here's the ratio of the
goods, X2 to X1 on this line.
As you move on this line,
that ratio stays constant.
We go up here to this higher
level of indifference,
the slope is the same.
So essentially, this
indifference curve
is a blowup of this one.
And you could draw
one out here, which is
a radial blowup of these two.
So you can scale up
and down, and just
keep the slopes the same
as you move, for example,
along either one
of these two lines.
So who cares?
Well it's going to turn out that
a household with these kinds
of indifference curves is going
to respond in a certain way
to income, respond in a
certain linear way, that's
going to allow us to,
for some purposes,
aggregate up over many
diverse households,
and act like there's
only one representative
Robinson Crusoe macro
household in the economy.
You probably don't
remember, but when
I went through the great,
big, long syllabus last time,
the next to last page
talked about aggregation.
And the lecture
on Tuesday will be
an example that violates
this kind of homotheticity.
Here's a violation.
We have a utility
function which is
linear in one good, x1,
which we'll call money.
And the log of x2 is not
linear, but it is concave.
So we call this the
money good because as you
inject or take away
good 1, utility
goes up or down linearly.
And it is also true that
if everyone in the economy
has linear utility functions in
x1, then the amount of utility
goes down when you tax somebody
is exactly the same amount
that utility goes
up for somebody
else who got the subsidy.
So again, that's a
useful property to have,
but it's very special.
Anyway, in this case, the
marginal rate of substitution,
which is not constant on
any rate from the origin,
the marginal rate
of substitution
is constant as we
fix x2 and vary x1,
so going along horizontally.
And you can convince
yourself that has to be true.
Because if you took
the definition, which
is the marginal
utility of x1 divided
by the marginal utility
of x2, the marginal x1
is constant because it's linear.
And this thing is
varying with x2.
So if you fix x2
and vary x1, you're
not going to change the
marginal rate of substitution.
So we have now
successfully reviewed
basic properties of
consumption sets,
consumer preferences, and so on.
You might want to squirrel
away some of those properties
because we'll come back to them
later throughout the course,
in the subsequent lectures.
But here they are,
essentially all listed now.
It doesn't mean they
all have to be true.
Some of them
contradict each other.
Theorems are if we have
local non-satiation
then a competitive
equilibrium is optimal.
But we may not have
it, in which case
competitive markets don't
work, and things like that.
So these are not requirements.
These are options.
All right, but now we
get to an application,
this partial
equilibrium problem,
which is to maximize utility
subject to a constraint
for the first time.
So this is the
budget constraint.
Income on the right-hand side--
I for income-- is
taken as given.
The prices are of each good.
There are n of them, p1 for good
1, p2 for good 2, and so on.
So the sum of the expenditures
at prices p over choices x
cannot exceed the income
I. So this is your budget.
We all have budgets.
I sometimes wonder
about the US Treasury,
its budget deficit,
debt outstanding,
is now larger than any
time since World War II.
But households have budgets.
And I'm worried
about the government,
but we'll get to that later.
So suppose you were to
double all the prices.
We start with this, and
we double income as well.
So we pre-multiply every term
by t, little t, both on the left
and on the right.
It's a constraint
in the problem,
but it doesn't
change the constraint
by multiplying through by t.
Or if you started with t, in
there, just divide everything
by t and you take it out.
So it can't change
the math of anything.
So that's one way to look at it.
I'll show you in the
picture in a minute
that no price illusion-- if
prices double as in inflation,
but your nominal
income also doubles,
no harm, no foul, at least
not for this household.
Now, maybe consumers
aren't rational
and maybe they're sensitive
to income movement and not
price or vice versa.
But for the most
part, we're going
to assume that
these are equivalent
constraints from the point
of view of the household.
And this is a definition
of homogeneity of degree
0 of individual demand.
The demand can't change because
the constraint doesn't change.
And here's the picture.
So this is the set of points
which completely exhaust income
when there are two goods,
x and y, P x and P y.
You could move over
to this extreme point,
take all of your
income, and buy good y.
How many units can you get?
Well, it's $10
divided by 5, or 2.
So we have a maximum
amount that would
be possible to
purchase of good y,
and maximum amount you
could purchase of good x.
We have exhaustion of
the budget on this line.
Actually in the interior, we're
spending less than income.
Consumer might not want
to end up in the interior,
but that has to
do with satiation.
What is the slope
of this budget line?
Well, you can derive
this the same way
we kept utility constant--
keep income constant,
take dI, set it to
0, and then take
the derivative of P X
times dX plus P Y times dY,
and you get dYdX is
equal to P X over P Y.
So the ratio of this line
is exactly P X over P Y.
It is kind of interesting
that only the ratio matters.
That is to say,
setting aside what's
going to happen
to income, if you
double all the
prices of both goods,
you don't change the
slope of this line.
In fact, more than that, we
could pick one of these goods--
say Y as the numeraire--
set P Y equal to
1, and then we'd
only be fussing about
the price of good X.
Here it's more general.
Everything's in dollars
or some unit of account,
depending on what
country you're in.
Could be measured
in wheat, goods.
Price is measured in terms
of how many bushels of wheat
you can buy.
So it's arbitrary.
You have to specify what it
is, but only the ratio matters.
That thing about inflation--
it's like doubling prices
and doubling income
doesn't change this line.
And where does the
consumer choose to be?
Here, C for choice, maybe.
So why?
Well, one way to view it--
the household wants
maximal utility.
So in the set of choices
inside or on the budget line,
what point has the
highest utility level?
It's point C. If you
go this way, it's less.
If you go this way, it's less.
There's another
somewhat interesting way
to view this marginal
analysis, which
is if you start it up here,
the slope of this indifference
curve U1 is pretty steep.
It's negative, but I mean
steep in absolute value.
And the slope of the
budget line is less.
That means this household's
willing to give up
a substantial amount of good Y
to get one more unit of good X
as he or she moves away
from B. But in fact, given
the prices in the market, you
don't have to give up that
much to gain value in order
to be able to purchase
X. You give up less Y.
So this is what you're willing
to give up and be indifferent,
but you are allowed to give
up less on the budget line.
So you're definitely moving
in the direction here
of higher and higher utility.
And you can conduct the same
reverse experiment down here.
So next, let's do a utility
maximization problem.
And as I promised last time, I'm
going to introduce a cool tool.
And it's called the Lagrangian.
So if we want to maximize
utility subject to a budget,
set up the problem in this way--
Lagrangian, which is the French
guy that figured all this out,
Lagrange, is to write
down the utility function
plus a shadow price lambda times
a repetition of the constraint.
So we turn the direct
maximization problem,
which was this, into
a pseudo problem where
the constraint is actually
in the objective function.
Anyway, if you start
taking derivatives
of this looking for the
first-order conditions
for a maximum, the derivative
of the entire expression
with respect to x k is the way
that k will enter and generate
marginal utility under
U. That's this term.
Plus, we'll pick up lambda.
And where else does
little x enter?
Over here somewhere, P k.
It's linear in x
k coefficient P k.
So we get this thing.
And again, we're looking
for an interior solution.
We set this thing equal to
0 as a necessary condition
for an optimum.
Lambda is actually a
control variable, too,
the way the x's are, just
looks a little weird.
We take the derivative
of the Lagrangian
with respect to lambda,
and obviously, we're
going to get the constraint
right back again.
And we're going to
set it to 0, which
we assumed before
that they wanted
to spend all their income.
We were implicitly
assuming before
that the marginal utility
of income was positive,
or in this case, that
lambda is positive.
So that's why we get the
constraint right back.
I'm not sure if you've
seen Lagrangians before,
but it's just a version
of multivariate calculus
where you find the
first-order conditions
to a maximum problem.
Note that we can take any two
pair of bundles k and j, i
and j, or whatever.
When you take them
pairwise, we're
going to have the derivative
with respect to good I here
and the price of good
I here and the lambda.
That lambda is the
same when we go J, J.
So we can divide the
left by the right,
and the lambda will disappear.
So we're going to get these
ratios of marginal utilities,
which are, of course, the
marginal rate of substitution
equal to the price ratio.
And that's what we were saying--
maybe I didn't say it--
when we have this
tangency over here,
the marginal rate of
substitution in utility
is the marginal rate of
substitution in the budget,
which is the price ratio.
So we're getting
that result back now
as a consequence of
this optimization.
Another danger-- I feel
like I ought to have
this slide that says, stop.
Pause.
Do not memorize these diagrams.
Just like the notation
becomes mind numbing,
you get used to drawing a
picture in a certain way.
And then when someone nasty
puts another specification
on the table, you don't
know what to do with it.
So here I am being nasty.
I'll show you n incorporated
it into the Lagrangian.
So this is a corner solution.
Where is the best utility level?
The highest level is here
because as you move down
this budget line
on the line, you
get higher and higher
levels of utility.
But if the
consumption set is all
of this non-negative [INAUDIBLE]
you can't go negative in y.
So you stop.
This is a corner solution.
By the way, you would get
this as well if the utility
functions were linear.
They're almost linear here,
and you have a corner solution.
Of course, they could
be linear and coincident
with the budget, in which case
everything on the budget line
is an optimum.
Or those linear
indifference curves
could be really
flat, in which case
you'll go over here
to a different corner.
It doesn't have to be
linear to generate corners.
This is an example.
But we need to incorporate it
into our maximum techniques.
So what's the general recipe?
Before we translate it into the
consumer optimization problem,
we'll get the technique down.
As I promised, you're being
gifted with a powerful tool.
So we have a function
f over a range x.
We want to maximize it.
And we have various constraints.
We have n of them.
g i of x-- g is a function.
There are i functions, each
of which, when evaluated at x,
cannot be negative.
Properties f and g i are
real-valued, continuously
differentiable.
In other words,
they're very smooth,
and not only continuous, the
derivatives are continuous.
How do we solve this problem?
Look it up in the cookbook,
or memorize it, even better.
There's a trick
here I'll show you.
The Lagrangian put the objective
function, just like we had U.
And now write down each and
every one of these constraints
with these Lagrange multipliers
lambda i for constraint i,
add them all up.
What's the little trick?
The g i is non-negative.
We enter it with a plus
sign, and then things
are going to come out
right with the math.
It's not necessary.
Things work even
if you write down
the g's as less
than or equal to 0,
but then you have to
struggle a little bit more
to make sure you've
got the math right,
and you didn't reverse the sign.
So anyway, try to do it
this way-- g i greater than
0 lambda g i.
Write out the
first-order conditions.
That's just a derivative.
So we're taking the
derivative of the Lagrangian
with respect to x k is the
derivative of the function
f with respect to k plus
the way in which x k
is entering in each
of these constraints g
i, each pre-multiplied
by lambda i.
Set it equal to 0, and do
that for every argument x k.
With me?
So next, write down
each constraint again.
Write down these multipliers
which are non-negative.
And this is cool--
this is called
a complementary slackness
condition, which
is the multiplication-- oh, it
should be a lambda i on that.
That's a typo.
Lambda i times g i equal
to 0, and then we're
going to look for a solution
to all these equations.
Now, if lambda i were 0
then it doesn't matter
what g is evaluated at x.
It's still 0.
Well, if lambda is 0,
then effectively, it's
not entering into the problem,
and you can ignore it, and drop
it by setting it equal to 0.
If lambda i were
strictly positive,
though, then the only way you
can get this product to be 0
is to have this g i be 0.
And that's here.
And this is what happened
with the income maximization
problem.
I asserted-- if we go
back now and look--
that the marginal utility of
income lambda on the budget
constraint was positive.
And if it's positive,
then we have
to set the budget constraint
equal to 0, income
equal to the sum
of expenditures,
which is the way we solved that
simpler problem to begin with.
So what we did
earlier generalizes
to this more complex.
Now, why are we doing it?
Well, let's come
back to this problem.
Are they necessary?
They could also be sufficient.
If that function f
is quasi-concave,
and the constraint sets,
these guys, are convex,
then finding a solution to
the first-order condition is
equivalent with finding
a global maximizer--
very powerful, and we will
use it subsequently, again,
to address the issue of whether
competitive equilibria are
optimal.
So going back to the motivation,
which was this picture--
we kind of know that we're
going to hit a corner.
What comes up with the--
if these were linear
indifference curves,
and you had this
linear budget set, then
when you take
first-order conditions
you're going to be in
trouble because everything
in the first-order
condition is going
to be parameters,
not control variables
that you want to find.
So that's a version
of being nasty.
But like I said, we're
working it all out.
So how do we deal with
this hitting the corner?
What does the Lagrangian find?
So we maximize utility
subject to the budget,
subject to non-negativity
constraints.
As in that picture,
consumption cannot go negative.
We form the Lagrangian
mechanically, which
says write down the
function, write down
each of the constraints, lambda
on the budget constraint, mu--
I changed notation--
mu k for constraint,
this one, the non-negativity
constraint on x k,
take the first-order conditions.
And now we get
something similar,
except that you pick up this
shadow price or Lagrange
multiplier on the non-negativity
constraint of good k.
Whereas before, that
mu wasn't there.
So then applying the
recipe, we write down
the constraints again.
We write down the non-negativity
of the Lagrange multipliers.
We have this complementary
slackness condition,
which is the product of
the Lagrange multipliers
with the budgets, and
we look for a solution.
If we were at a
corner where good 1--
or good x, whatever
was in that figure--
were 0, then if we go back
here, this would be positive.
This mu k would be positive,
and we take it out.
This would then be less than 0.
Something less than 0 plus
something positive makes it 0.
We leave the positive
thing out, and we
get the thing that's less
than 0 looks like this.
And what this says,
essentially, is--
there's a number
of ways to read it.
Let me do it this way.
Put lambda over here.
Lambda is the marginal
utility of income.
So how much income does
it take to get good k?
And what are the utility
consequences of that?
p k is the number of dollars you
have to give up to get good k.
The utility of those
dollars is lambda.
So lambda times p k
is the marginal cost
of getting a unit of good k.
And what's the marginal benefit?
The marginal utility
is the benefit.
In this case, the marginal cost
exceeds the marginal benefit,
so you don't do it.
In fact, the
solution, obviously,
is to set x k equal to 0
because at any positive level,
the marginal costs are higher
than the marginal benefits.
The best you can do
is to set it to 0.
So Cobb-Douglass utility-- this
was an example we had before.
Good X and Y to power
alpha and 1 minus alpha
subject to a budget--
you can solve this.
It's really not necessary
to go through in class.
It's a good example.
You maximize.
Using the Lagrangian, you get
the first-order conditions.
Do some algebra with that
first-order condition
comparing ratios.
This would be the marginal
rate of substitution.
This is going to
be the price ratio.
They have to be equal
for an interior solution.
And the solution
has to be interior
because the marginal
utility is going
to infinity when one or the
other of these goods goes to 0.
So you never want
to go down that far.
We can rearrange these terms.
And the bottom line
is, p X times X
is the expenditure on X, and
it's equal to alpha times
if I. If you go back to
the utility function,
alpha is the power on X.
So whenever you see
this Cobb-Douglas,
you can immediately jump to
something you should know,
which is the expenditure shares
have to do with these powers.
The expenditure shares
on X would be alpha.
The expenditure share on
Y would be 1 minus alpha.
We want to see that in notation.
p X times X is the expenditure
share on X at the optimum.
It's alpha times I.
Likewise, p Y times Y
is 1 minus alpha times I.
So you have your whole budget.
You spend the whole budget.
And the share of the
budget you're spending
is dictated by the alpha, and
1 minus alpha, and the prices.
So that's constant
expenditure shares.
And again, when you go to
data, you go take a look.
And we'll do that in the
lecture on next Tuesday.
Now again, we got
through all that stuff--
hopefully useful, maybe
even interesting to you.
And now you've forgotten
about geography.
You've forgotten about time.
You've forgotten about
states of the world.
So let me end with two slides--
the lecture about
consumer choice,
when the consumer
decides how much leisure
to provide or negatively,
how much to work
and how much consumption to buy.
So it's going to be one
thing to say right away--
leisure is going
to be a good thing.
Consumption is a good thing.
So those axes that
were labeled x and y
are now labeled c
and l, where c is
consumption and l is leisure.
So it looks standard now, but
it's a much more interesting
problem.
It's how much to work problem.
It's like the
bicycle messengers.
The other thing is maximize
utility subject to the budget.
So this is kind of a
twist because instead
of having income
over here, we've
got the wage, w, per unit
time times the time endowment
that the household
is endowed with.
So this is as if you took
your entire time endowment,
worked all of it, and then went
back and bought some leisure
and bought consumption.
Probably a more
obvious way to put this
is to take wl, subtract
it from both sides.
Then you have T minus l.
So time minus leisure is
the amount spent working.
You surrendered
it to the market.
You don't enjoy it, but
you do get the wage for it.
And then this becomes
income, and income
is spent on consumption.
The other thing
about this problem
is like the choice
of a numeraire,
everything is measured
in terms of consumption.
There's no price.
You could have done it.
You could have price of
consumption times consumption,
price of leisure, the
wage times the leisure.
But we just normalized wages.
So this is what's
called the real wage.
It's how much consumption
bundle you can
get for a given unit of labor.
And here's the picture.
So you're effectively starting
here, with 16 hours a day
of leisure.
I don't know, some sleep is
allowed, eight hour bedtime.
The remaining is 16 hours.
But you may want
to earn some money.
So if you move in
this direction,
you're giving up a unit of
leisure, working that unit,
and getting the
wage for it, which
allows you to buy consumption.
So the slope of this
line is the wage.
In this case, the
wage rate is 10.
So every unit of
work that you supply
gives you 10 units
worth of consumption.
And you could work your entire
16-hour day at a wage of 10,
and have 160 units
of consumption.
But this guy is
stopping short of that,
where the indifference curve
is tangent to the budget line.
So this is the choice
of how hard to work.
And again, I could have put
in a dynamic choice problem.
I could have put time--
consumption today versus
consumption tomorrow.
We're going to have one of
those at the end of the lecture
next time.
As a constant
reminder, we could have
had choice about locations.
And we'll do some of that
pretty shortly, as well.
All right, so that's
the prepared slides.
And we have one or two
minutes left for questions.
All right, so you
have all the slides.
Take a look at them, study them.
You also have the
review sheet questions.
Go back and take a look
and make sure you're
able to answer them.
We'll have a little review
next time of what we did today.
And then we're going to go on
to explore these expenditure
shares, and income
expansion paths,
and whether poor people
consume luxury goods
or the opposite, et cetera.
So that's for next time.
I've already mentioned
last time something drawing
on a real application
from the material we're
going to do in the lecture
next Tuesday on China,
and kind of varying these price
ratios of these budget lines
by subsidizing
consumer purchases.
It's a wonderful
problem set, worked out
by one of your former
classmates, actually,
who I hired as a UROP.
So you're almost in
the position to start
to take the look at that,
especially after Friday,
and certainly after Tuesday.
So that's all I have for today.